[Music]
what's up reject nation my name is John
Humphrey over there is Greg Alva usually
in this position I'm in right now and to
the center of us is my good friend
Keaton Markey we go way back we worked
in a haunted house together and yeah so
taken by this because I'm like trying to
believe this but I'm also like there's a
cat and runs blankets beautiful but
anyway to the sandwich arts peer
entertainment has a new video out a
20-18 trailer-trash up which I can only
imagine is gonna be an amalgamation of
every trailer from 2018 through that
with a heaping amount of Deadpool meta
craziness you guys ready for this I'm so
ready I am so ready John are you hanging
on the edge you see I really don't even
know what I'm about to get into oh good
cuz that's the best way to go first one
I saw I didn't know what I was getting
into either and it became a low-key
classic so let's do this thing so many
trailers just Boop and so little time
what was our misguided solution take
pieces from all of them and create
something far lesser than the sum of its
parts Love Train we dubbed it a trailer
trash
not dubstep obviously we can't do my
trailer because it's already a spoof but
we can't offer you free cable what the
professor wants to see the principal's
office
Colossus narc on me I just have one
question
when cap needed help if I have nothing
will you come I guess we'll never know
but if you had you'd have never been
caught and bring the airport to the
ground
what's permission for today yeah you
know what I think I'm gonna go this one
alone
thanks Scott my name is rave minutes
my dad picked that name because he
thought it sounded like a superhero's
alter-ego might be awkward or Bruce
Banner full weight Wilson ooh ouch
what's your name slowly my name leap
across by Nature
leapin is my specialty
right they're expecting you on the
second floor what kind of King you don't
I'm going to be a mighty king do not
sing that song
did you ever choose not to you know
something I don't think I ever have
ignite throw I did got some serious
vacation time saved up and I am
respectfully declining this mission
[Music]
I heard a story about you I was
wondering if it's true everything you've
heard about me mister you really made
love to a womp rat don't believe
everything you hear this trucks 240 mm
here who said I moved out of his
apartment for 239 and he's walking off
the elevator
you work for Norman Osborn William
Stryker will I'm sure Baron von Strucker
I think you're just jealous of my
brilliant career why can't you be more
like my previous boyfriend longer they
just had to go bigger for the sequel
[Music]
how does he throwing these in such rapid
succession hold on
you gave her wings and blasters so I
take to not have that tech available for
me well I didn't want to start a war off
with more than you can handle so I
designed these they're made from the
same polyethylene foam as pool noodles
so it's unlikely you'll cut yourself you
won't be able to fly but you'll look
intimidating and these are high pressure
liquid soap dispensers try and aim for
the eyes give you a few months to get
used to the new suit and then maybe we
can talk about removing the training
wheels
anyway sis you could be whoever you want
to be except Batman
[Music]
[Music]
except when I went to send Ariana that
was really cold
I remember you got very sick it's
magnificent dance
of course my fraternity is refused to
allow me to take off my signet ring for
this movie so naturally it has to be
digitally removed when did you promise
me a solo movie this is not what I had
in mind tell me how much do you love
your family well that's difficult to
quantify I mean how long is a piece of
string you could say my love for that
will die hard
you tell a boy by for me Tony about the
mission rather did you see anything
unusual just this one alien he's bad
news though he gets your number
books restaurant sends flowers but come
tonight he never shows up
they call them the pre dater Easter egg
inside the Oasis the first person to
find it will become dog it's been five
years where is this thing I know I keep
saying this but are you sure it isn't
that it up there does that look like a
chocolate Easter Egg to you Artemis stop
wasting my time I'll take two
that'll be 5000 euro to accept
archaeological relics not from first
time customers I think this was where
you these bandages were used to wrap
Tutankhamun's athlete's foot right the
priceless their putrid no thanks
maybe you've got me cash I risked my
life for these this is the point of all
this tomb raiding if I have to give up
my dream of shooting people with both
hands welcome to the most advanced
nation in the world where we choose our
leader based on who fights best in
shallow water every time I defeat an
enemy you must not be a very good
fighter than what no I do it to myself I
do it on purpose did you know I'm space
them apart what did you always allow to
kill this exact number of it all you
need to know is I can't space a just for
you well the design appears completed if
I was kidding you I would say knock
knock who's there
baka da
we'll call the what work undermines
himself
sorry TT Cabo de gata secretary weapon
[Music]
this ship is like an ancient but
majestic bird I'm gonna call it the
century sparrow oh 109 years old
you look great me I'm twenty-two hard
life no not particularly
why what do you mean they got away I was
given the opportunity to capture the
largest piece of Pez in history that
wasn't a mission
Ethan the mission changed so you're
saying it's a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for watching why don't have a
digger on that channel you may all know
that you don't treasure or just get
really dirty but we would appreciate it
I can't speak for myself no argument or
fraternity
oh and don't forget to subscribe hi hey
Yukio and maybe Sonic teenage warhead
what did you think of the trash shop I
thought it was trash I can't believe I
skipped detention for this well that was
very negative a teenager all we need now
is they're incredibly like mimicking
it's just these two I think they're a
couple like a hundred percent solder a
couple which is the most beautiful
relationship I think you can have yeah
just like a full-on creative little
imagine playing like that in the bedroom
just change your voice do anything at
that point what you think of your
introduction arts peer entertainment I
loved it that's hilarious I want to go
back and watch more of their videos just
because that one was so funny my cheeks
hurt oh you fell down a rabbit hole it's
an easy channel to binge watch they do a
lot of these trailers boots and such I
kind of appreciate it how they decided
to structure this because I thought we
were in for oh my god we're gonna cover
so many trailers it's gonna be nonstop
which sounded cool to me because I was
like that would have been cool if we got
like this Shazam let me get the Aquaman
one oh great yeah there's a bunch that I
thought you definitely could have
included in here but I think for the
structural standpoint and the fact that
they wanted to match them all up sort of
like by the end of it all and plus you
know so they don't kill themselves over
the you know we're never doing I thought
that the way they structured it was
actually really neat these guys are such
hard-working talents
I guess their animators as well do one
of them do it or do they I think I think
it's just them - they do it all by
themselves but you know John and I we
just watch their videos usually by
ourselves which is just as easy hole is
hard it's equally as hard we gotta pay
attention yeah we have to look at the
screen a lot you know we have to know
what the characters are we have to give
[ __ ] feedback by the end of it all
yeah I know we have to sit here right
now and break it down as if we have a
lot of intelligent things to say about
it
which we don't most people clicked off
the video by now you know so you know we
really have the harder job at the end of
it all emotionally especially they're
talking about chocolate again it says
five chocolate Easter eggs reoccurring
see I was editing while they were
filming other videos every time I had to
pause while editing how is your
chocolate this video brought to you by
Charlie good substitute for brain is is
chocolate in the venom universe like
their venom voice
not-not-not venom there Tom Hardy Boyz
yeah right southern accent yeah yeah
this weird like squeaky almost southern
actually I work for us don't wander
around here anymore don't want right
well and just I mean some of those
moments got so silly like when he's like
returning Carlton Drake's home
belongings and stuff like that along a
sucker for good puns but knock-knock
joke about that Donn's himself into our
giant people and I'm so happy to writer
because as soon as I saw Rock leap I was
like if Tomb Raider does not leave was
and the rock with all those diehard and
towering inferno puns about like what
skyscrapers a combination of I didn't
get my fist coffin Henry Cavill no I
hope they were making fun of although I
I really loved cuz like that was the
thing I was thinking and throughout the
whole original trailer was like what if
he just decides to not accept it just go
please I am respectfully declining this
mission it was very gratifying to see
that played out for in actual
you know this is a credits roll the
thing about kill mongers scars like the
things he does on himself for every kill
yeah I never thought about like that's a
great joke I just think about that yeah
I was like wait what like you really
thought you were gonna kill exec yeah I
thought so thank you I also had the same
thought to sing I just can't wait to be
king so thank you the voice of freakin
two cellos yeah that sounded just like
him lupito was great - it was bad yeah
there are some of these that sound
grabbing Tom Hardy southern did it makes
any sense to me but most of that sounded
perfect it was great Hanson sounded
really good too with me in her solo
movie I mean some of these are not
parodies of the trailer like ready
player one I'm like well now you're just
spoofing the actual class scenes from
the movie at this point you know Batman
I feel like this really what would
happen if we had a place like that as
you would not everyone but so many
people would be Batman and as soon as
you will have multiple avatars of these
characters you know so there are some
great points that were actually brought
up in terms of the actual film medium
that they're doing and you know what I
also like their position some people
might not be a fan of the really cheap
jokes I love cheap jokes anyone knows my
comedy really the predator creator free
dater
such a stupid juice not a sucker for
jokes like yeah I don't quite understand
I haven't seen the movie so I why it was
visually moist so me man jokes are a
little bit weird to me in this one as
best I could gather they're just
treating Scott like a baby and hope as a
you know warrior and that was kind of
the theme that trickles right I mean I
thought it was kind of funny the way
they expanded upon the not so souped up
ant-man suit as compared to he's got
like a little training wheels on his
ankle
spencer's and stuff I guess that was
probably the weaker portion of this for
me but uh even still even still they
work a lot harder than we do they do
yeah so subscribe to our spirit amen go
show them some love also subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell to get notified every
time a review or a video is out also
follow Keaton Markie on the social
medias people Twitter Instagram wherever
books are sold and you know Greg you
know mean we're the real rejects we'll
see you next time peace this is